salut à tous c'est pêcheur de trésor
alors aujourd'hui on est toujours avec
Wim et Dani on est au bord du canal
regardez al c'est pas un canal c'est une
petite rivière qu'on va sonder elle est
remplie de vas c'est un canal parce
qu'il y a pas de courant alors sur
Google Map ça peut s'appelle rivière ou
ruisseau mais si quand appelle ça un
canal il peut l'apper un canal mais
l'avantage regardez c'est que ça passe
sous la route une route très passante et
il y a aussi une maison abandonnée là
qui était un sorte de S c'est ça et
aujourd'hui on n pas pris des cordes on
a pris nos perches parce qu'on va aller
dans l'eau et on a appelé Wim qui est un
professionnel de ça ouais vous avez sa
chaîne ici qui s'affiche ouais n'hésitez
pas à voir sa chaîne regardez il est
plus grand que nous donc ça lui permet
d'aller plus loin aussi dans les
ruissaux ouais et il comprend rien ce
qu'on dit alors regardez le look qu'il a
avec son bonnet
ok allez on att c'est parti déjà une
trouvaille à peine il vient d'arriver
dans l'eau
d'
ok ok il y a de l'ence is
ok wou scooter un scooter wouh super
c'est un bon début vidé donc là je vais
aller chercher une corde on va
l'attacher et on va le sortir de
l'eau regardez on envoie les Hollandais
dans l'eau comme ça nous on se mouille
pas il travaille pour nous l'autre jour
à jein on était à 5 pour tirer un
scooter donc j'espère qu'on va arriver à
4 il a l'air plus petit plus petit et on
a des des costaud avec N oui des
pêcheurs allément oui
on
[Applaudissements]
s'chauffe un bébé avec de de personnes
çait le faire mais
de
PLA
la meilleure façon de commencer la
journée
conratul
super
3 vous savez quel mod
c'est alors
tu ça y est on attaque la pêche
[Applaudissements]
B oh yes ah oui on dirait un
gouvernail regarde c'est un gouverna de
bateau
cool la va c'est vraiment drôle on est
on s'enfon ça fait tout tout mou très
drôle cet
endroit quand tuas un deuxième scooter
peut-être qu'est-ce qu'il nous
font
[Musique]
ok
chingad
unad ah c'est pour les poissons ok donc
c'est un matériel de pêcheur
bien
joué que
ouais
Grou peut-être un camion ouais peut-être
ça vient d'un camion ça un vieux volant
ouis sympa j'ai l'impression de
descendre l'Amazonie comme my cororn ah
il y a un truc
ok Mitou
Mitou de roues en même temps ok bon on
continue à nettoyer la rivière c'est
mieux que rien donc deux autres pneus
ouais là je crois j'en ai un
[Musique]
autre bon il y a pas grandchose on va
aller un peu plus sous le pont et on va
voir ce qu'on arrive à
trouver tu vas
tomber tu veux nager mais tu vas
tomber qu'est-ce que tu fais
Baptiste qu'est-ce que tu fais
Baptiste regardez
regardez il m trouvé des
pièces
[Musique]
on trouve rien mais il y en a un qui se
régale pas vrai
rastaa c'est pas de la maltraitance
animale c'est lui qui voulait venir dans
l'eau rasta impassible face à
l'agresseur ils te font pas peur
rasta tu as raison ils sont que quatre
tu risques rien tu es le plus fort oui
tu vas leur casser la
gueule allez oui met en plein
travail
bicyclette
OK c'est un pied de Bich mais
cassé is
sa allez il y a tout pour ouvrir le
coffre fort maintenant on va le
trouver qu'est-ce que tu fais
là allez on va regarder sous les ponts
ok un
pneu belle
trouailleessaie de passer avec la perche
d'abord il y a moins de vas sous les P
ça d être
nettoyé ah ou
ouais oh Spon une petite
cuillère toute propre
tiens partie de
voiture commencé à
l'intérieur alors là c'est compliqué on
va essayer de tirer
voouyez les aimants marchent
bien ah
il a pas grand chose puse bien on
traverser dere côté le
temps BO a les
triangles le
triangleok
Nice ok le lustre avec les les PES qui
tournent pour pour
rafraîchir super on continue c'est du
bois ah non c'est pas du bois c'est de
l'AL j'ai quelque chose je suis oui mais
oui mais encore là-bas moi j'ai avancé
et j'ai trouvé un Asus
regardez comme il est
beau l'état du
truc ça
pu Intel
Core Windows
génial
gros
d'échappement B
pollution un
vélocathon
ok
s préféré de Quentin
ok un
sac
M
m
VO médicament et
caillou les
P ok
non OK
de
[Musique]
chocolat j'ai tré une pièce B yes
queen On regarder combien c'est de
pénis
d'oreill c'est de l'or ou
pas c'est pas de l'or c'est une
serviette hygiénique ça désolé
hgiéqueenabeth la reine
Elisabet pas évident on pas pas asse
pied c'est trop
profond j'ai quelque chose
mais
laite ok
[Rires]
ok
joli
[Rires]
sanglier
sanglier not pigvage pig ah bon ben
voilà c'est la fin de la vidéo regardez
tout ce qu'on a pêché aujourd'hui ouais
joli scooter ouais on s'attendait à plus
de choses sous ce pon mais bon c'était
propre tant mieux ouais c'était sympa
quand même encore un grand merci à Wim
et Dani qui sont venus nous rejoindre
pour cette pêche àément et qui nous ont
appris la pêche avec la perche
d'ailleurs si vous voulez trouver une
perche elle vienent du site de maison de
la détection vous avez moins 5 % sur
tout le site avec le code promo pêcheur
de trésor et nous on vous dit à la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo de pêche à Mar pensez à visiter la
chaîne de Wim qui est en description il
s'est lancé ils ont trouvé des
dingueries vous le savez il est avec
nous sur la vidéo à Bruxelles il pêche
en Belgique mais aussi au Pays-Bas à
Amsterdam notamment on va vous afficher
la vidéo à Bruxelles en fin de vidéo et
maintenant bonne douche